i have a 19 year old neighbor and he was
trying to be a millionaire every month
he was trying to be a millionaire with a
new thing
i was like if you could sign a contract
with me and i said i could guarantee
that you'll be a millionaire in 10 years
but you're not going to make anything
between now and then when you sign it
he said yeah i'd sign it and i was like
cool this is your employment agreement
now you're working for me and you're
gonna start cold calling i walked in on
him while he was trying to close the
deal once and he hung up and i was like
dude it's like i know what you have in
closing deals he's like what i was like
you suck at sales
and he was like
how do i get good at sales and i was
like
you sell
he's one of the top closers on our team
he's worked his way up three rungs of
the ladder in our sales teams and now
he's 19 years old making 150 grand a
year he's taking everything to heart
he's got hustle this is just the
beginning of his journey there's lots of
other skills along that i'm going to
start putting into place so that when he
has done that instead of having a
four-year degree where he's going to
learn how to chug beer four years from
now he's going to have 500 000 saved up
and he's going to have all the skills so
that he can start his next thing the
right way with experience inside of a
business knowing what it's supposed to
be